doing the Wasabi thing it's like the
equivalent of like sniffing markers as a
kid one makes you
dumb the other is wasabi maybe I'm a
glue
sniffer hello and welcome to another
episode of trash taste I'm your host for
today G and joining me once again are
the boys and this is going to be the
least controversial episode we've ever
had on trash taste I swear we say that
every
episode why why is it going to be not at
all it's not going to be controversial
because you know every 3x3 episode there
has never been zero controversies uh
because we're doing another 3x3 episode
guys where we just talk about stuff we
like we haven't done one of these in a
while have we what was the last 3x3 we
did I think it was music yeah music was
it that was like two years ago what the
[__] yeah we're just sharing things that
we like that mean something to us and
what could be controversial about that
right so we decided for this episode
episod uh the one thing that we often
like to talk about on trash taste is
food but we've never listed out some of
our favorite foods so we decided to make
a
3X3 of food 3x3 a food 3x3 I don't
really know what that meant it just kind
of it just means your nine most favorite
or the nine foods that Define you the
best how did you guys go about putting
together your list what kind of
the heart did you I I have some which is
like I I have a very great attachment to
for nostalgic reasons I have ones where
it's like I can eat this in any
situation any time of the day and then I
have ones which are like this is kind of
a secret Banger you know these are ones
where it's like it's it's not the number
one secret bang only
[__] it's the it's not a number one
charting kit but it it has a cult fan
base type of deal you know cult fan base
in your heart yeah cult fan Bas in my
heart nonstop bangers just now that's
what I
call bers we'll be the charge of that
nonstop bangers That's What I Call food
that's what the album cover is going to
be my three yeah for me it's just like
these are the dishes where I was
thinking about you know how sometimes
you like crave a dish and then sometimes
you think about eating that and you're
like I'm not really feeling that these
all of these dishes I could eat anytime
no matter what where I am where I am me
I feel like that's how I've decided like
you hand this to me I eat it if you hand
these stuff to me I got time I don't
need to be craving it cuz I always am
craving it no matter what uh okay we're
all on the same we're all on the same
base level in that regard but now it's
up to what we actually we have to
discuss but let's not let's not judge
each other let's not judge each other
right let's remain what's what's the fun
in that let's remain civil in all are
you saying we're like 180 something
episodes in and we're suddenly not going
to judge each other I just think that we
should you know understand each other a
bit more sometimes I like we don't do
that on you telling it to yourself no no
no I just I just know that I'm you guys
are going to say mean things so I just
think you say nice I don't think you're
going to say any mean things about mine
one mine are all just like [__] off what
did you do like oh pizza and I like I
like I like chicken and I like U um
[__] P tie pretty much pretty much I
swear to God if you have the most basic
list I'm going to be so pissed off yeah
then we're going to criticize you're
going to look at my list and you're
going to be like yeah this is gone we're
going to criticize you for being too
warmy has to be a food that you look at
and you go objectively I know this is
not like the top food of all time for
other people but for me it's a banger
yeah I don't
know I don't know if there is I was
trying to think about if I have any hot
food takes and I have no hot food takes
what do they do to you when you were a
moner he's too content all right uh
shall we get started with the list I
believe we are once again going to be
having trashbox Kun up and about um
we're resurrecting him right now we are
resurrecting him stuffed with our names
we have to we have to create a seance to
to get back from the dead so if this is
your first 3x3 episode if you don't know
what a 3X3 is it's a it's a list of
basically a uh as it sounds like a
3X3 which is nine which is nine top n
top nine Foods math of us occasionally I
math all right all right first up
is G all right I swear to God if we go
in the this order all right all right
all right let's let's I kind of don't
want to go last let's let's get my list
up let's get my list up all right what
the [__] am I looking at
here so let me let me explain this right
now because okay hold on okay oh no
maybe maybe just leave it there we'll do
both do both we do both we do both all
right hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold okay what okay okay so let's go in
order so from top left to right we have
we have uh padow okay uh which is My
Thai comfort food uh to white people
right saying white yeah we have uh
McDonald's breakfast oh my God uh
specifically the Ed like okay so Pizza
Hut had this limited edition run the
cross had this limited edition run that
I discovered when I was a kid and I
still internalize and remember this to
this day it's called The Edge is not on
offer anymore but I I dream about this
[__] if that if they bring this back I
am going I am flying all the way to
England or America just so I can eat
this again but you have to have Pizza
Hut it's the edge okay let's not get it
right now let's just let's move on then
uh we
have any you you I don't care what
chocolate it is you a chocolate Fiend I
don't care what chocolate it is you put
it in Easter egg form I don't know it
just tastes 10 times better I don't know
why I could eat Easter eggs all day
obviously lasagna that should not
be I kind of realized this when I was
making this list but I just like wings
not like fake Wings just like I just
what is fake Wings you know what fake
wings are I don't know you Me by fake
Wings what do you mean by fake Wings
boneless wings they're not fake Wings
they're very much real wings I I real
just [__] love chicken wings and I
love I've loved them everything since I
was a kid yeah chicken wings um on the
bottom left that's not specifically
Sushi that's just salmon niri oh okay
just salmon just salmon niri just salmon
Nigi okay no tuna no white fish nothing
like that okay no got it uh on the
bottom it is smoked meat American
barbecue like spare ribs and Sh all
right sh BG yeah uh and on the bottom
right is instant Ramen Shin instant
Ramen uh Shin specifically or just Shin
specifically instant Ramen I might come
out a little bit of swinging here all
right gapow honestly not not the best
Thai food there's so much better Thai
food out there I I will say that the
reason I put grapal on uh isn't because
I thought it was isn't because it's I
think it's the best type food okay that
was a bold thing for me to say to a
time let
me you really came out swing con really
said let me tell you let me teach you
about your own culture let me just tell
you right now your your
food you have better food than this guy
this is not your strongest fighter
that's what I'm saying okay here's the
thing grapal right if you go to a TI
restaurant right I think every like
everyone who has like who has like a
grew up with a Cuisine they have this
it's it's like the test about if you go
to a restaurant of a certain quisine
everyone has like that dish to test the
quality of that restaurant it's like a
steak for like like other places yeah
yeah sure to me I order always uh I
always order the grapel first as like
the Baseline test of like if this is
good if you can make this slap probably
most things on this menu absolutely
[__] slap because gapow is like to me
like the Thai comfort food right
everyone knows how to make it everyone
knows how to make it you can find it
pretty much in most Street places in
most places everywhere you go in
Thailand this is available right so to
me this is not only like my comfort food
every time I go to Thailand it's not
like the food I always I always am like
raring to eat but to me this is the
Baseline taste test of everything that
Thai food represents and you need it's
it's like Bas basically like you know
when Gordon Ramsey asks someone to cook
an omelette you know if you can't cook
this correctly I do not trust you to
handle anything else about my Cuisine
yeah I think for me gapow leveled up you
know like that uh that picture of uh uh
Donald Duck when he has a boner and then
he's in the
air that me when I when I started
putting the fish or the what's the fish
sauce is it fishu the fish sauce on it I
was like holy [__] this is like a
different dish now okay so you need to
put the uh yeah the fish sauce with like
the fresh chili chopped in it it was
like a different I was like holy [__]
this tastes so much better oh yeah yeah
yeah that I mean that's that's what they
serve it with in Thailand yeah and I I
didn't know that CU obviously when
you're in like a British restaurant they
won't give you the cuz it does smell
horrific oh it does well not horrific it
smells quite nice but it's just so
strong and even like a tiny little
container but when I started adding it
to it I was like wait yeah galaxy brain
moment like I'm like this food is so
much better now yeah I Prett slabs and
like you know in terms of like Southeast
Asian kind of like
rivalry um me and mein get into like
[__] friendship ending arguments on
which Tai versus Vietnam on which
country has the better fish SCE
sure I I will die for N I will die for
and's like
no my opinion is I think the Tai one's
better hell yeah I like the Vietnamese
one too but I think personally I prefer
the ti one can I say the pad TI is kind
of mid yeah you can can I said okay I
don't I don't like I don't I I have you
ever have you ever seen me order pad Tha
no I mean I like pad Tha but it's not
the best that's like the introduction
for white people to Thai food had Tha
like oh this is kind of cool this is
rather this is kind of ethnic guys right
and then you eat it a bunch you're like
wait this is probably like the least
flavorful thae dish it it is uh I think
I think one thing about thae dishes uh
like Diet Thai food well I say least
flavorful thae dish it still has way
more flavor than like 99% of British
food that I gra yeah I kind of I kind of
realized this after you know trying
different kind of Cuisines which is you
know like Japanese Cuisine especially
and obviously British food uh which is
Tha or a lot of Southeast Asian Cuisine
is just packed full of flavor uh which
is kind of why I think you know I really
like Nando cuz Nando was the closest
thing to reminding me of something that
is not exactly you know Thai food but
has that kind of like same like flavor
profile like we talked about uh one of
our you know Japanese staff members who
complained that Nando's had like too
much flavor too much flavor you know
which is wild that's a crime you can't
you can't describe like that that's
[__] up and to me like Tai food has
always been you know now that I've tried
different Cuisines it's it's like like
the ingredients we can get in Thailand
aren't the same as [__] wagu beef or
like you know some of the pork sausages
we can get in England but we make up for
that [__] by just chucking a [__] ton of
spices and a [__] ton of meat uh sorry a
[__] ton of like chilies and flavor in
it and that's how we make up uh make up
for that and uh sometimes more is more
and that's fine sometimes sometimes
adding more flavor is great like let's
not let's not reduce it all right so gal
makes sense uh explain the [__] [__]
sausage egg
McMuffin do I need to explain the
sausage egg McMuffin okay in a in a
[__] 3x3 though this is like a ride
or die food yeah yeah um I like it I
actually had it yesterday oh my God I
mean I like it don't get me wrong I'm
not going to say no to one did you did
you get it delivered though or did you
go to the store you can't get it
delivered I just feel like it's a
different item when it's delivered uh I
sometimes get it delivered you know when
when I'm hung over when I'm hung over
but okay D it has like a 5 minute window
of being good the Egg McMuffin wait
which one do you get do you get which
which which McMuffin do you get the
sausage and egg McMuffin with the hash
browns I I could include the hash browns
in this but it is it is the set as a
whole the sa sausage egg McMuffin and
the hash browns you know what you know
what I'm a [__] fiend for this there
are more times where I order two of them
than when I just get one one does not
satisfy me do you do the double or do
you do the single if I can get the
double I'll get the double one double
over two singles I I'll get two doubles
dud that's four sausage patties dog they
are so good familiar with your game guys
you know what okay okay this might this
might be a hot take I genu I generally
do not care about McDonald's that much
compared to their breakfast menu their
breakfast menu few their breakfast menu
to me eclipses anything else like I
actually don't normally crave McDonald's
like generally like I know people like
get deep [__] craving for McDonald's
me I'm I am people me I'm have to stop
you right there G let me to introduce an
item called the McDonald's fries when
they are fresh uh they are unbeatable
unmatched as a fast food item uh they
are the best thing known to man and
there also some of the burgers I like
more yeah I like I like the burgers my
problem with the McDonald's breakfast
and has been a constant theme throughout
my life and somehow normal McDonald's
doesn't do this to me uh the breakfast
items in particular make me feel awful I
feel get the [__] out I feel compared to
the rest of McDonald's I can eat a Big
Mac I don't know what it is about the
Egg McMuffin I love it but holy [__] do
I feel like I've been through the ringer
when I've eaten it I only I only get
McDonald's breakfast when I'm like
severely hungry I also also I'm going to
put I will never eat it so I'm going to
put me on the cross right now I do not
like the hash browns in the breakfast
okay I don't I
don't here's my complain I was on your
side you said that listen here's my
problem everywhere in the world
McDonald's they're too oily there's too
much oil in the hash brown okay
McDonald's is the one place where you I
know I know they're supposed to be oil
but they just put a little too much man
but that's what I mean like that's why
that's why I I only eat this particular
combo of sausage egg Mo muin with the
hash brown on a morning where I'm
severely hung over cuz otherwise I feel
like [__] but like I know people who
will go to McDonald's and get five hash
browns in the morning I'm like how is
your stomach alive all right to flip on
his head McDonald's has Brown is the
only hash brown I like okay that's
that's a
fair I'll it like to me when I get like
a full English they have the hash browns
over there and I I eat it and I'm like
the only thing I can think of is man I
just wish I had a McDonald's hash brown
right now every a lot of it's very
stodgy generally like it's a lot of like
just carbs I mean the thing about the
McDonald's has brown is like yes it's
greasy I think it's like the perfect
amount of grease to me but like it's
it's also it's also like I don't know
something like the thinness of this the
thinness of it as well and it's got that
sometimes it's not always like perfectly
crunchy sometimes it's a little bit
chewy but it's like soggy the word soggy
I would I wouldn't say chewy not chewy
it's soggy G let's be realistic here
let's be growing up it kind of crumbles
in your mouth because a little bit soggy
I okay I don't like hash browns if
they're too crunchy okay you you have
them raw right you don't add any sh to
it no no I I have them raw that's crazy
to
me I have themar do I I have a bite raw
and then I'm like hold on I need I need
like the vinegar of the the ketchup to
help with the oil here H sorry with the
um like yeah the vineger of ketchup to
help with the oil of the hash brown I
don't think ever used sauce on a hash
brown before I love ketchup with hash
browns it's like it just that actually
makes so much sense I don't know why I
never thought to that why it's literally
FR no that's why that's why hash browns
are perfect cuz they don't need [__]
ketchup in them they don't need anything
McMuffin doesn't need any cond I will
admit the of the breakfast menu the
sausage McMuffin is the best one all of
the items are red herrings you should
not order them people who get the bacon
one I don't know what the [__] is wrong
with you it is not a good item it tast
the inferior one no it tastes bad all
I'm saying is that uh you could just
remove every menu item from McDonald's
aside from the breakfast menu and
McFlurry and I will be very happy no I
would I wouldn't be I live my life I
would be I think I would actually prefer
that knowing that the breakfast menu was
avable all day all in America only in
America that ruins the Mystique of the
breakfast menu the the the reason why
the breakfast menu is so good is because
you happen to wake up with the boys and
you you happen to be at McDonald's the
boys at 9:55 a.m. and you're like guys
we can make it yeah we can do it the
golden five minutes you're like we it's
11: right 11 it ends right I F I'm not
sure what time but in UK I think it's 11
anyway you you've made it in time to
experience the double McMuffin think
I think the only time I've ever ordered
a McDonald's breakfast is when I've
stayed out all night to the point I've
missed the last train and it's like 5 in
the morning and I'm like I guess I'll go
get McDonald's that's the only time I've
gotten it you know part of the reason I
think this or if I'm on a [__] road
trip with Chris yeah Chris is a
McDonald's fan yeah part of the reason I
think this is
um maybe maybe this is a hot take I
don't know if it is because you know um
I just don't think McDonald's is that
good anymore I don't know wait anymore
as in like since whene since I was a kid
I think I've just grown up like I I
remember like I had this point you got
[__] edgeless Pizza there what you
want what are you talking about look I
don't know if something about me has
changed but every every time I've
ordered McDonald's like within the past
four or five years yeah I have this
mental image about how it tastes when I
was a kid and then I take a bite did you
have McDonald's like birthday parties uh
I don't know if I had McDonald's
birthday party but like so then You'
remember if you had McDonald's you would
remember that' be that's a Canon event
okay the kid's life I think I went to
McDonald's birthday parties but I never
had one for myself I went to McDonald's
birthday parties but yeah I mean like I
[__] love McDonald's obviously as a
kid teenager it's just they come for
food and you know what you know what
ruin me with McDonald's ironically
enough I think America ruins me cuz the
American McDonald's bad no no not just
the American McDonald's but America in
general just
America eating American fast food and
and tasting how good fast food can be in
America ever since I had that like
Awakening of just like what's the golden
standard of fast food oh this is what
this is what fast food should taste like
the what's the golden standard F fast
food like what's the best fast food
American joint go best fast food
American joint even just going to
somewhere like I don't know uh I know
five guys isn't in the same realm but
just like Culver uh you know any kind of
like any kind of necessarily a burger
join right yeah I'm also thinking about
places like Chick-fil-A and you know
other like fast food establishments ever
since I had the ceiling that like the
taste of that ever since then after
after then I've tried ordering
McDonald's and that Magic's just gone I
every time i' order nugs I'm thinking oh
you're getting nuggets what's wrong with
nuggets awful I like the Nuggets why
they're like the most tasteless piece of
rubber in your life yeah ever since I've
tasted American fast food I've gone back
to like I've just not craved McDonald's
at like anymore except for McDonald's
breakfast which is still goated and I am
completely [__] I every now and then
I get the craving to get a double
cheeseburger or a Big Mac every now and
then I'm just like I can't shake it
there is nothing else right now that
will satisfy that need than a double
cheeseburg or Big Mac all right just
doesn't taste that good it it doesn't it
it doesn't taste it it kind of like blew
my mind to realize [__] I've been
programmed to like this stuff because I
liked it as a kid and then I have like I
actually bite down to have a taste and
I'm like [__] I don't think this tastes
as good as I remember it I don't know
man I don't want to hear this coming
from the guy who put the Edge from Pizza
Hut on his list I love the [__]
double cheeseburgers and mcdonal oh dude
they're so good okay explain the [__]
Edge what the [__] is this come on okay
what is this OB obviously it was my
introduction to realize that's crustless
pizza pizza hot pizza hot okay I will
say I Pizza Hut no no do not defend
Pizza H wait wait wait wait what are you
saying to to completely just disregard
my previous argument about McDonald's
and like childhood memories and all that
[__] Pizza heart just has this certain
smell that no other Pizza Joint can like
yeah it has the smell of like day
kitchen grease what know I love it when
my my my pizza I can break it over my
leg no no no no no no like you know how
Subway has that smell like whenever you
walk it's it's such like an iconic smell
no it's not iconic Sor it's not it's not
it is when you go there but like it
smells it smells way better than it
tastes right sure to me like to me no
other Pizza Joint like the kind of like
mainstream pizza joint no other
mainstream Pizza Joint has that unique
smell except for pizza heart I don't
know what it is but all of them have
their own unique smell see I don't
understand this because I think I was
one of those weird kids who never got
like chain pizzas like I never like my
parents never ordered from like pizza
heart Domino like my dad made pizzas
every Frid we never got them I don't
know this like I don't have any like
Nostalgia with like Pizza Hut or Dom
okay I did because like uh you know when
when I was growing up a broke ass kid
uh like they I can't remember what day
it was but one day of the week they
would do like all you can eat pizzas at
Pizza Hut and that was that was like my
pizza intake for the month a UK thing I
went as well that's crazy I did like
that a lot and and that's how I got
Pizza Hut pilled and then I grew up and
I was like wait this is the worst this
is the worst of all the pizza CH what's
the best one in the UK some people say
Papa John's I think Domino's in the UK
is really good right right I think do I
think I think they're really good I'm
not really like to
me sometimes like I I think taste wise I
prefer Papa John's but sometimes I just
get that craving for a pizza h i get the
craving for just that the whiff of that
smell whatever that Pizza Hut smell is
all pizzas the [__] Pizza Hut Edge is
in your top nine yes Psy I dream about
this [__] man you know why it's
unobtainable anymore because you can
make
this it'sing your judgment because it's
unavailable you think it's better than
it was this is [__] [__] I because we we
there are pizzas that are like this that
you know are available which is kind of
like
the cross P but I been searching every
time I I look for in America I see this
kind of pizza and I'm like this is going
to be the one this is going to be the
one that gives me back the memories
again this is going to be re relive my
childhood but it's missing that smell
it's missing that Pizza Hut smell of
just whatever that Pizza Hut smell I'm
pretty sure they just you know sprinkle
this with like happiness and okay well
that's not true an angel dust or the
sadness of underpaid star
interpretation that must be what it is
Pizza in recent years is just a sad
shell of what it was and even when it
was at its peak it wasn't very good
either yeah pizart fell off um just not
fall off yeah I think it might fall off
in the US especially do you know why it
fell off because they got rid of this
off their menu once they bring the edge
back back to West tier baby bring back
the cold classic yeah off cuz it
[__] I mean like to me obviously I'm
going to enjoy a crustless pizza but um
also just okay so so are you saying the
only difference between this pizza hot
Edge and every other cross lless pizza
is that every other Cress Pizza is not
made by piz is that what you're saying
pretty much also also what I can't
fathom is that we had this whole big
[__] deal about how I said American
Pizza was better than Italian pizza and
here you are putting a [__] American
style pizza on your 9 by9 best foods of
all time when you looked me in the face
and lied to me about saying that the
other style of pizza was Superior I mean
how do you apologize just hasn't come
around you apologize the Italian look
look look I am putting something on here
that is like to me if they brought this
back I will happily admit that
American but it's not obtainable anymore
okay it lives off in the dreams of my
childhood okay it's like waiting for the
second coming of Christ you like it'll
happen one day you are like Preposterous
how could he even consider American
Pizza be better than the superior it one
day and when that day comes I will be a
believer
again your aliances are paper thin G the
Bible could drop a sequel and I'd be and
pizza could drop the edge like a rerun
of the edge and I'd be like all right
all right Bible two Bible two all right
Italians do you hear this this man
didn't care about your pizza he wanted
something better this entire time he was
hoping the Americans would swoop in and
save the day
still please please just just re-release
the edge please you I thought you going
to be like Pizza H please sponsor us
what you just give me back you know I
don't need like I know it kind of
recently had a rerun in America and I
was dumb enough to not fly to America to
just relive that dream and I regret that
every moment of my life okay but
hypothetical if you did right
hypothetically you flew back hearing
about the edge two coming back right the
edge
two the edgeing uh you know you hear
that it came back right and you buy it
all right and you're expecting all the
Nostalgia to flow back what if it's not
the same it will be the same but what if
it's not uh what if there just something
about the the recent Pizza Hut as
opposed to your childhood yeah and what
if the Earth is flat Joey it's not why
you ask me a why you ask me a hypo
hypothetical question would you still
love it huh would you still love it yeah
of course of course you're in full Co
mode dude I can't believe you're I have
no doubt that I will love this exactly
the same absolutely not but there's no
way to prove it because they never going
to bring it back until they do until
they do and then hey if if trash taste
fans put enough PE pressure on
pizza if they do I would actually like
just fly to America I I would look for
like bring back the edge yeah I would
look for an excuse to visit like Sid's
family and it'll be like okay but the
real reason I'm here
is Mom Dad take me to Pizza H right now
isn't it um which style of pizza is it
where Square um is Chicago style pizza
is no that's yeah Chicago square one no
it's Detroit right am I crazy Chicago
yeah they have the square one where the
middle yeah the middle pieces are like
Edge yes the edge there's no no crust
it's just the middle no no no but you
don't understand it's not made by Pizza
it's not made by pizza oh my God that's
the whole point we're getting at that's
why this is stupid this is so [__]
dumb this is dumb your your this is
dumb all right right chocolate and egg
form chocolate chocolate egg form
explain this what the [__] I kind of
understand you're coming
I hate to admit I kind of get where
you're coming from with this I don't
know why explain it to me okay so
sometimes a chocolate bar just way too
[__] much I just I just just like a
chocolate and bar do I relate to this
you know what I mean like a chocolate
and buff and like here's the thing it
has to be a hollow egg I've had like
completely solid chocolate egg where the
[__] have you gotten solid eggs from oh
they make like the kind of the smaller
ones you [__] so that's like half the
global chocolate Supply that not I know
I like to me an egg is just the best way
to present chocolate I
don't like there's just something that's
just I just have really good memories of
Easter time yeah right you know
and think about as a [__] Tik Tock
with that sculpting chocolate guy where
he makes like the [__] and then he
sculpts it into like a bird but it's
like a full-on dick for like long you
know what I'm talking about yeah I know
exactly what you're talking you show
chocolate [__] sculpt the the Tik Tock
guy I don't know what I don't know what
I don't it's always like whenever you
scul something it's always like [__]
shaped until it's not it just starts off
like oh wait it's an eagle oh yeah of
course of course I knew it's an eagle
what is this penis
l no work made of chocolate yeah yeah go
to one more uh maybe click that Reddit
one
yeah yeah it's this [__] guy it's
always it's always the this [__] guy
yeah this is the one this is the one
that looks like a dick get this
shot wait wait wait let me see check
this out yeah okay so yeah
okay oh my God he knew exactly what he
was doing
making KN KN there was a snake I knew it
was a snake the entire time I knew it
was a snake too yeah that makes sense
holy [__] that's impressive I would have
know better if it was a [__] it was like
massive [__] if it was actually a [__]
anyway back back to the sorry this is
just what my distracted by chocolate
[__] all right all right oh this is a
dragon I thought this was going to be
the eagle um yeah uh sorry penis [__] uh
that's penis [__] um I was I was like
you mean I was like trying I was like
trying to oh yes so you're saying
everything is better in egg form now
explain your logic for that cuz I don't
understand this this okay so like I it's
like when it's an egg form it's just the
perfect thickness okay it's it's
sometimes you bite into like a chocolate
bar and it's just too [__] much it's
just like way too hard it's too much
chocolate to chew for to chew through
but with what are you [__] 90 with
Dentures what are you talking about but
with like it's like it's too it's too
much sweetness all at once right it's
too much chocolate with like a chocolate
egg you can just break it off and it's
just like break it off it's nice little
bite-sized it's like eating potato chips
you know yeah yeah yeah it's like the
perfect size and shape and thinness you
know you can get like little little bags
right of like Mini Chocolate so you can
have like little like bite-sized
chocolate no no no no no but that's
still too thick it needs to be like like
it needs to be like it's the idea that
you can just break it off like that yes
it's like just nice and thin and you
could just break it off like a bigger
piece and it's just it's just so much
more fun also makes the best noises when
you into a lot of chocolate bar there
are a lot of thin chocolate bars out
there um that exist they're not egg
shaped they're not egg shap they're not
egg shaped like it doesn't the [__] is
the egg sh also it's that childhood Joy
when you got one of those massive ones
during the Easter and you just like can
I break it smash it and then doing that
still fun as an adult Fu you smash it
wait wait how how' you eat an Easter egg
well like like a regular size Easter egg
yeah okay so you you get like a large
Easter egg right like like how big are
we talking uh like kind of like kind of
kind of like you know kind of like this
size where it's not like bite size but
it's like one of one of like the larger
ones at the supermarket right do you do
you take like a first bite or do you
break it oh I break it you break it do
you smash the whole thing oh yeah what
that was my favorite thing dude when I
was a kid I used to give my sister the
whole the egg as I'd [__] like punch
it in like that and that was the most
fun that was the most fun thing
Barbarian so fun you meant to like make
a little indent and slowly chip away at
it no what's the fun in that because it
keeps the form of the egg it doesn't
matter I'm going to eat it all in a day
yeah then you can you can snap it into
sizes that are preferable instead of
having crumbs everywhere cuz the worst
part of the egg which is why I don't I
don't agree with this take is that more
often than not it just ends up like
crumbling or little [__] crumble
pieces in the egg I [__] love though
because because you know then you can
[__] love I'd love my microscopic
bites of chocolate oh it's great it's
like it's not great it's like micro
doing on chocolate yeah yeah yeah yeah
because because like when you get to the
end of the egg you have like this little
pile of like chocolate crumbs and you're
just
like what the [__] I hate that I I
totally all of a Twist I don't want
[__] crumbs of chocolate totally it's
it's like a little extra it's it's
similar to like guess it's the
equivalent of cleaning off the potato
chip bag exactly that's it that's the
best part yeah I don't know know like
this is just to me the best way to
present chocolates if I could just go
without a chocolate bar and just be sold
chocolate Easter eggs all year round I
would buy the Easter egg what kind what
kind of chocolate are we talking now are
we just talking like Dairy chocolate
white chocolate dark chocolate what's
your
favorite I mean I'm I'm like a basic
[__] I just just give me like dairy
milk chocolate milk um I prefer dark
chocolate I I prefer dark chocolate I
also like white chocolate I know it's
not chocolate technically but I do like
it a lot but to me like to me to me
white chocolate and dark chocolate like
they're they're completely different
things to me right to me okay I this
just contral to wh okay no no they I
guess how can how can I exp yeah I was
going to say cuz you you're saying it
like they are different things that's
crazy like yeah yeah uh they inhabit
different moods that like I I crave them
but like it's only in like certain
situations the dark chocolate I want to
have at the end of a meal maybe with a
coffee I don't want to I never want to
have a ton of chocolate though I just
don't ever want to eat a full bar to me
I can have like milk chocolate anytime
any mood I've had a toon in my fridge
for the past year and I've every month I
take a see that's the problem with Toons
I [__] love Toons they're too thick
uh yeah yeah they are well I mean if we
had to in an egg form I destroy that
holy [__] you're so right Joey I would
destroy in a day if it's in heck form
turone all day long where are they
yeah the whole point of the to but the
chocolate itself is so Banger if we had
that exact same flavor I'm going to blow
your mind in egg form it's Banger cuz
it's thick and they can fit a lot of
little [__] in there no no no no no
there there's enough thickness in the
eggs it's not you just were saying how
they need to be thin so now let's which
one we're not talking like paper thin
we're talking like not a [__] it's
it's always like the perfect thickness
you know it's the perfect thickness of
chocolate which is not like paper thin
you know there's still some text to it
there still you know you still get like
the chocolate enough chocolate flavor
but it's just not overwhelming you know
it's chocolate eggs best way to present
chocolate AG all right this is [__]
lasagna [__] lasagna's just the best
pastor I I disagree with that it's just
the best P I feel like I'm being a
contrar on p i I actually just don't
think that's the best pastor what's the
best pastor um I hate to say this but I
think like as I've gotten older lasagna
has been slowly going down my ranks of
pasta tier list cuz to me it's like it's
almost don't don't say some like bougie
[__] like noi no I don't like Noy that
much noi's too starchy uh I think
lasagna to me is like almost as I get
older is closer to like pizza and like
deep dish than it is to like traditional
pasta you saying that like it's a bad
thing well no I mean it's like but I
think like lasagna is far far more far
removed from pasta than I initially
envisioned it being um yeah I kind of
agree with that it was my favorite when
I was a kid yeah cuz it was like
pizza pizza they just kind of like it's
layered Pizza like yeah that's no
crust like it that's why I [__] love
it this is like lasagna is basically
like without the cross it's improved
Pizza you know it's everything I look
for I do want to prefence I do love
lasagna but I do actually think I prefer
traditional pass faite more we'll get
into that later oh okay you have it on
your list all right all right all right
uh I mean this one is kind we have to
talk about chicken wings this one is uh
self-explanatory Everyone likes chicken
wings bone in or bone out Everyone likes
it how much do you like it though do
chicken wings yeah because I will say
this like every
time uh chicken okay for me chicken
wings is one of those things I don't
necessarily crave but if it's on the
table I will devour it I'm I'm I'm going
[__] be honest I kind of died a
little on the tour that we did because
uh every [__] time we did not get
chicken wings once and we got chicken
tendies every every the US tour the US
tour no no no there were there were a
few times we had the when on the bus I
remember there were a few times where we
ordered [__] bone in because you
wouldn't shut the [__] up about
it all right we'll get to [__] Boney
in for G cuz he's bitching about this
too much yeah I I mean I can understand
this wrong I think I was close to
putting uh Wings on mine I like wings a
lot obviously I like boneless chicken a
lot and my allegiance is more closely
aligned with boneless but I do love
Wings yeah yeah I mean to me like bone
combo bone in wings uh I was trying to
think if I had like a singular flavor
that I liked cuz I remember I I was like
my mom always Cooks these like tide
chicken wings and I think that's where
my love of wings came from where I think
I've just I like it got to the point
where I think I ate wings at least once
a week damn for like for like my entire
childhood not a bad childhood at all
Japan needs to absolutely stop up then
need stop putting hormones in the
chickens cuz this this [__] is so weak
bro it's like you get like it depends
where you go though you get quarter of a
bite on a chicken you been to yamama
Chan chicken yeah but they're tiny yeah
but you get like a lot you do get a lot
sh but it's like you literally you
like Japan uh does need to level up
their chicken game a little bit it's cuz
they don't put but I think like America
also like their wings are
too they are stuffing that their wings
way too much the reason that wings are
my favorite part of the chicken out of
everything is because to me wings have
like the perfect skin to meat ratio a
lot of the times age with that like like
to me the the most important part of the
Wings to me is the flavoring of the skin
cuz that's where most of the flavoring
comes from and then the meat is kind of
like the let's say yeah the the enhancer
to that uh but to me the the main star
of the Wings are uh the skin and even on
like [__] thighs you have the skin
which is there but there's like so much
meat so you're like you enjoy you enjoy
the skin and you're like [__] all right
I got I got I got to finish this meat
now you know I got to finish this meat
um yeah when you order like 10 wings in
Japan versus 10 wings in America one
will not fill me up at all and the other
will make me obese I I'll be so full
yeah so like to me to me wings has just
been like a staple of my childhood and
I'm discovering like to me I think
Korean wings are my favorite now uh
that's the pH I'm going through they're
definitely there I think Korean Fried
Chicken is the best fried chicken in the
world I agree uh just the way they fry
it and the batter and just the flavors
Fried Chicken really the Yan sauce
bro I I like honey honey garlic soy
sauce oh the honey garlic is good too
honey garlic is so good honey gar this
episode of trash Chase is sponsored by
vessis guys if you didn't know if we
didn't have vessies we would not survive
at all we would literally die if you
look at any picture of us in the past
few years you will notice that we are
all and always wearing vessies that's
right we love vessie so much so it's so
awesome to hear that vessis is coming
out with some brand new stuff guys
finally some new Footwear I could put on
my feet for example look at these
beautiful pair of shoes right here those
the shos they're 100% waterproof I heard
also made with Advanced Materials
ensuring your feet remaining dry in all
weather conditions and they also have a
gusted tongue with diatex technology
that incorporates the latest in Footwear
technology and guys it is winter right
now but I am sweating I am sweating
because this overcast coat I'm wearing
is just so too good good the overcast
coat is 100% waterproof and has a
stretchy shell with an interior soft
fleece lining ensuring for added warmth
in those chilly days but Connor I see an
even dripper pair of shoes right there
I'm glad you asked these are the altar
they are 100% winter essential tailored
for winter with extra grippy SES and a
cozy fleece lining inside ensuring you
always stay warm in the coldest
conditions but Joe what's that you got
on your hands oh these These are the
vessie waterproof gloves that's right
they don't just do Footwear they do hand
wear as well to make sure your little
thingies stay warm in this winter Joey I
have no idea where to go if I want all
of this don't worry Conor all you have
to do is go to vy.com trashtaste that's
vessie
docomo lot more than very much vessie
for sponsoring this episode back to the
video all right so specifically salmon
wow I I kind of had this realization the
least Japanese sushi of all time yeah
okay so I kind of had this realization
where um out of every Japanese dish that
I thought I would eat the only thing I
consistently eat now um as like a
comfort food that I'm constantly craving
is Sushi I don't really go out to eat
ramen uh you know I I [__] love so
many Japanese dishes but the only one I
like I view as a comfort food probably
Sushi I don't don't really like highend
sushi places because they don't normally
serve salmon and I realize I realize the
reason I love going to conveyor belt
Sushi is because everything I order
revolves around salmon niggity honestly
oh my Lord honestly conveyor build Sushi
gets too much of a bad rep like I don't
know why conveyor Bel Sushi is bson it's
[__] good actually I actually way
prefer convey Belt Sushi than highend
Sushi plac I mean highend sushi places
do just taste different
um it's whether or not you prefer one
over the other I mean I like like if I
went to high sushi place I really like
it but uh if I go to like sushi doll or
something I'll [__] it I I'll go down
with the salmon and mozzarella [__]
thing they did I'm like that's pretty
fire okay it's not sushi but it's good
here's the question how much Wasabi did
you put on it zero oh like 100 I don't
put any I hate Wasabi I cuz like I I
think the reason I prefer conveyor belt
Sushi is because I can like just soak
that [__] in I can just soak that soy
sauce Wasabi and I'm [__] okay okay
first of all first of all are we are we
talking about uh Wasabi when you get it
like the the fresh stuff cuz it tastes
totally different to like the
horseradish what you're not going to get
the fresh [__] at Sushi no I know so
we're talking about okay we're talking
about the horseradish now we're not
talking about horse radish right yeah
horse radish for me it's it's like I
don't know if it's like a genetic thing
or what but for me it's like a gas
attack on my like thing it feels like
it's just unpleasant it's not there's no
flavor part of it that I enjoy and I
really want to like it cuz like it goes
well with sushi right everyone tell you
but uh for me it's just like it's such a
harsh uh pungent like Flavor that I
can't do it dud I put so much my [__]
turns
green fresh Wasabi it's like it's much
more mild it's it it tastes a lot
different real Wasabi is not even s
that's not me trying to be bougie they
are just ex they are actually just two
different things one of them is not
wasabi
the horseradish yeah I mean that's fair
like I wouldn't I wouldn't I I that's
crazy to me but I like the horse radish
but I definitely prefer real Wasabi it's
it's like uh you know like every time I
go to like a highend sushi place they
always have like the perfect kind of
balance between fish uh rice and just
like the amount of Wasabi and it's like
nicely balanced yeah I love that but
sometimes I just want to gas myself I
don't know sometimes I just like the
Feeling Just and I feel I feel like a
drag ad eggs a little bit like every
time I have like it all comes here I
hate people call it spicy cuz I'm like
this is not [__] yeah it is not it is
shares no similar feeling it's just it's
an impact yeah to me this is like the uh
adult equivalent of like you know if if
you are a person that's uh you know you
like putting a [__] ton of Wasabi on
your sushi and just being gas that's
crazy to me that you like salmon with a
[__] ton of horseradish yeah I [__]
love it it's kind of like the exists and
uh Cho with Wasabi as well is great like
Cho is way better CH too is like I can
only have one yeah what about like
normal Toto huh normal norami like
regular tuna akami is I don't know some
Sal just has like that perfect balance
to me I mean it's not even my favorite
yeah yeah I don't know like to me it's
like the equivalent you know doing the
Wasabi thing it's like the equivalent of
like sniffing markers as a
kid you
know yeah I get that except hopefully
there aren't any like detrimental health
results but one makes you dumb as [__]
the other is the other one is socially
acceptable I I you know that's I think
that's kind of why I like Wasabi you
okay it's a little wild maybe maybe I'm
a glue sniffer I don't [__]
know but yeah specifically like every
Sushi trip revolves around how much
salmon sushi can I order that seems
socially acceptable to balance out with
the rest with the rest of the Su I do
think that like I said they sush does
this mozzarella salmon thing it's
actually fire really you should try it
haven't been to sush in a while like on
Chris's video apparently sush was saying
it's like one of the most popular items
in the menu it's it's not Sushi it's
it's salmon rice mozzarella and then
Basel dressing that sounds good it's
actually it's so good it's so yeah
that's like a carao dude all I can say
it is carao with rice it's good all I
can say is thank you Norwegians for
introducing sermon to the
Japanese single handly feeding the
Japanese you've uh made the you you've
made their dish even better in my
opinion cuz you don't normally get sushi
uh salmon sorry salmon sushi in high-end
sushi restaurants all right ribs or just
or just American barbecue in general
American barbecue or rib okay okay this
is definitely going to be hot take you
you got to pick one okay uh definitely
ribs I think brisket is overrated yeah
brisket is overrated I'm going say too
it's overated explain to me what exactly
is a
brisket uh [__] that's a great question
cuz I always get confused what exactly
is a brisket what what constitutes as a
brisket um I actually don't I couldn't
tell you what a brisket is part I think
it's a part of like the we un yeah we
are we are definitely uneducated but cuz
I don't think I had this growing you you
no no this just like a no if you've been
to like an American restaurant uh
brisket is normally one of the comes
from the lower breast or pectral muscles
of the cow yeah so normally this is the
one that smokes the
most um yeah my my my issue and I've
started having this now with um I love
American barbecue but the I don't know
if this is cuz I'm getting older uh the
Reliance on needing an ungodly amount of
source is starting to turn me off uh cuz
brisket needs Source like if if you have
it on its own it is it it is too much uh
it needs to be mellowed out with a bunch
of sources and americ my God they're way
too sweet they load it up with the
sweetest goddamn barbecue sauce yeah if
you go to like Kansas City that's why
that's why I love Texas barbecue is
because it doesn't always rely on that
sauce there's like the dry rub as well
which plays into it I I will say Texas
barbecue I think is [__] goated yeah
go ribs is yeah but I I also liked
Kansas City Barbecue more which is
sweder traditionally but I like the rib
rib is my favorite part I will say rib
rib is my favorite part but I like I
think I just like smoked meat I don't
know something about that Woody taste
that you know I think America
controversial opinion I think America
loves to claim they do a lot of the
things the best like fried chicken like
um pizza hot dogs they do barbecue the
best I give but I one thing I will
defend them on is their barbecues are
the best American Americans you did
barbecues right and I down that Hill you
get a platter you get like [__] mac
and cheese you get beans beans and then
you get like two you get like you get
ribs uh but ends are okay depends how
ends are great depends depends on how
much how how much sauce I can handle
yeah out of out of everything I think
brisket is my least favorite just
because it is it is a bit too much I I I
never have like ate eaten like I I
remember the first time I actually felt
like sick after eating a barbecue was
when I was in Texas and I had the
brisket it was specifically the brisket
cuz it was like so fatty and uh yeah
when it's too fatty when it's like when
it's like too fatty this is like it's
not the same kind of fatty as like wagu
beef kind of fatty it's like a different
kind of fatty um this was like more than
like 10 McDonald's hash browns put
together kind of like oily fatty you
know yeah yeah some of them are a bit
too earily I my statement earlier where
I said like I'm getting older don't like
it I still love it but I I find that I'm
craving it less and less right yeah but
I I I still like if I'm in America the
one thing I always want is American
barbecue uh one of my favorite
restaurants in Tokyo is an American
barbecue you always go there cuz I
always crave it man I'm like the one in
Harajuku yeah one The Smoke House right
oh I [__] love Place ised yeah I
found an American Barbe place near my
house and I go there like plac there's
there's a lot of places now actually I
need a beer to go with it cuz I need
love I have to have beer with it it's
getting it's getting a nice beer with
American
barbecue oh I just tast I can understand
this being on the list I don't give you
too much for this one great [__] just
my only complaint of ribs is you always
get too much or too
little in America it's always too much
in America it's always too much in Japan
you're like really $10 for one rib are
you [__] kidding me would would you
like a rack of two or a rack of 20 no in
between dude I'm not kidding a rack of
ribs in Japan like a full rack is like
$60 it's insane it's for like a for like
a good like American style done well
it's ridiculous I'm just like wondering
does any other Cuisine focus on Smoked
Meats like I'm I'm trying to they must
be but we're probably dumb enough I'm
probably dumb and I've never tasted it
before but yeah this this just has such
an advantage to me just because I don't
know why you know specifically smoked
meat you know I know that I know other
places do like smoked cheese and stuff
like that but I
justbe there I know there there's got to
be other quis there's got to be other
quis out there um but for for what I
know like only I've only experienced
Americans in terms of like really
specializing and really honing in on how
to like properly smoke meat and I
[__] love it uh some of my favorite
meals is when I when I go to Wisconsin
is when you do kind of like not even
like a professional smoker but just like
a more kind of like I I know a few
professional
smokers but just having that fresh Woody
fresh Woody taste [__] love it uh
smoked meat all the way from me yeah I
can't disagree with that it's it's great
yeah and uh to end things off
obviously I was like what uh food means
the most to me sh Ren uh I knew I had to
pick an instant Ramen because that is
what fueled me through most of my life
like you know I only just realized
looking at this 3x3 now this is like
college student with a little bit of
expendable income
diet you know I I college student who
can afford food this this is the ramen
is just everywhere um every single
country on Earth has Shin Ramen which is
fine but if you can get indomy it's way
better it's way tastier the MSG is on
God levels indom me is the best I prefer
the nakam Moto uh that you get from
7-Eleven those are B the problem with
Japan is they don't they don't use
enough MSG they need more MSG need more
MSG you need more for instant noodles
you need an ungodly amount of MSG I I I
know I'm betraying my own bloodline here
by not putting Mama noodles on here uh
which I was heavily considering but then
I just kind of realized that the problem
with the problem with you know my own
country's noodles is that the packaging
the packets size is never enough and I
don't know if my phow ties can like
agree with me yeah agree but like it's
just fellow tie I agree with this this
tie statement I you your noodle size is
a joke you got to you got to add 50%
it's it's it's like one packet of Mama
noodles unless you get the extra large
packet which isn't normally on sale
outside of like Thailand but like
busting out two yeah yeah it's it's like
two is too much but one packet is way
too little so you just end up wasting
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah to like to me
like to me this is like the perfect
amount of instant noodles that also
taste [__] great as well um I didn't
have this when I was growing up uh but
when I discovered this I never looked
back I have more Shin uh ramen noodles
in my house uh than I do Mama noodles I
mean I used to not be able to eat this
growing up cuz it was too spicy but now
now I [__] love it it's great it's
like the perfect amount of like spicy
which is not like
like to me it's not like an ungodly
amount of spice I sometimes have to add
like a little bit of spice to it uh of
course but to me it's just it's if I had
this in college this would all this
would be all I would be eating because
yeah you'd also have a sodium overload
as well I lot of other problems I would
happily have the sodium overload well
not a bad three say some hits some
misses I I would say like going back to
going going back to the lasagna thing um
um like one thing I wanted to say was I
never understood why spaghetti was
always the most like popular pasta dish
worldwide spaghetti is the worst pasta
it's it's like I think objectively
spaghetti is just the worst pasta and
one thing that kills me in every like
Italian restaurant I go to that it's
always just different flavors of
spaghetti dishes that's American though
that's a very American thing is it
American yeah in Italy it's I spaghetti
is there but it's nowhere yeah
spaghetti's very selective it's like
it's nowhere near as common as some
other types I'm just wondering why did
we choose why did the world choose
spaghetti as it's the worst one it
doesn't absorb the pasta sauce that well
it's way too thick when you get like you
have to like [__] spin it up there's
way too much [__] like Pastor ratio
to Source It's never enough every other
Pastor form like you think about like
the I don't [__] know the names P
Linguini yeah all of these ones you can
get a much better source to Pastor ratio
going on uh and it absorbs it better
like it'll hold the I can't think of any
like pasta dish that normally is like
you know done with spaghetti that would
not be improved with other pastas I
wonder if it's like an easier EAS easier
to make thing might just be easier to
make yeah yeah and cheaper to cuz all
all they have to do is pass it through
the pasta machine like shape it surely
like any shape would be easier to make
with I don't know how to make dog pass
the shaper you know surely surely
anything does it work like a cookie
cutter system or or is this more
convoluted I don't know like the
standard like uh spaghetti with uh like
what is it marinar what do they have
normally with it like the balles bhet B
it's so basic like I I to me like an an
Arata with like just the penise is so
[__] good so much better yeah that's
like a an easy one as well like and it's
more flavorful I think and well I think
it's also just because Bolognese is just
a a flavor that is also easy for
children to eat as well like kids can't
eat [__] AR you know and it's super
easy to make as well
who says they can't that's we're not all
we're not all born with high [__]
taste buds all
right even spicy I couldn't eat arabiata
are you [__] shiding me when you were
5 years old you can't eat a [__]
arabat yes you can yes you can I could
kids got to suck it up he'll he'll suck
it up eventually all right well that's
fine that's fine all right well that was
that was my 3x3 this video is sponsored
by gamer Subs guys you know I love my
Gam game of Subs you know what sometimes
I'm just not feeling an energy Jing
right now
guys I will kill
you but thank God they released
something just for the occasion God
gamer te they have gamer tea now gamer
te oh my God give me a wishes he could
was British he'd only be drinking this
no he'd be he'd be doing me je no Conor
he'd be doing what I'm doing which is
Jew wielding right now with my gamer tea
which ones are you drinking there G I am
drinking the Connor tell me because I
don't even know let me tast you're
drinking the black tea I think taste it
and oh gamish very British the ginger
and turmeric you should very much be
able to taste it we don't have the box
right here I don't oh this is really
good but did you know guys that there
are four different types of gamer tea
that are available right now we have
black tea ginger turmeric sleepy Thyme
and yata each box come with 15 tea bags
bags should be added to hot water like
you would normally to make hot tea and
guess what each box is $15 USD more tea
more tea more tea oh my God I'm more
British just by drinking this game of
tea guys so put that [__] cattle on
boys cuz you're drinking tea also some
big news gamer Subs is launching waiu
cup season 5.5 royalty see what you did
there very nice if you buy any of the
Season 5.5 royalty Wu cups you can get
one of these boxes for free and of
course you want to get 10% off any of
your orders on the gamer Subs website
use code trash tast use it use code
trash 10 off use it right now thank you
so much for gamer subs for sponsoring
this video and letting us say dumb stuff
in the read we really appreciate it back
to the episode let's go next one shall
we who's next let's find
out it's me all right Joey come on get
it up Joey Joey all right get mine up uh
prepare
[Music]
yourselves what the
[__] all right here's mine what the [__]
is this do you have spaghetti bolog and
a what the
[__] what the [__] are you on about bro
why you think so
quiet spaghetti bow and AES is the worst
pasture this is this this almost felt
foreshadowed with this with this [__]
timing I have a good reason for putting
spaghetti Ballona on my 3x3 okay all
right but nothing can be good enough
Joey but uh I have strawberry short cake
skim in uh kangaroo sausages
specifically kangaroo uh Nat watermelon
spaghetti balles miso soup Sukiyaki and
chicken
paicos which one would you like to hear
first what the [__] Strawberry Shortcake
I've never seen you eat strawberry never
eat a strawberry shortcake from oh dude
it's the only cake I can eat why cuz
it's Strawberry Short Cake to me is the
perfect level of sweetness because like
every other type of cake I have is
either not sweet enough or it's way too
godamn sweet cuz I don't really eat a
lot of sweet things to begin with I
don't eat desserts um so but anytime
there's a strawberry short cake it
[__] slaps and I'll eat it every
single time but if we have if there's
like fruit cakes or like chocolate cakes
or any other types of cakes I'm very
selective it's like a mood type of thing
Strawberry Short Cake I can eat anytime
and I can just [__] pack that away
you C this sh did you crave it Joe yeah
it's the only if if I see it in like a
restaurant menu or like if I see like a
cake place that has a strawberry short
cake I'll buy it it's the only cake I
crave every other type of cake I'm just
like eh whatever I'm not a cake person I
don't think I've ever craved a cake if I
think about it uh no me neither yeah I'm
trying to think if I've ever craved a
cake for me to criticize this I think
it's it's so it's so weird
basic basic so basic saying what the
[__] is that thing and you're saying
it's basic no I it's just it's just cake
with a bit of strawberry in it yeah
that's why I like it it's fine it's just
sponge cake with it's very strawber one
thing I will say is that is it
specifically the Japanese Strawberry yes
all right because the thing about
Japanese cakes that I can like kind of
like is that it's very uh light fluffy
flavor I think nice but then they put
like an ungodly amount of cream on it
like I love that I love that yeah and I
love the fact that it's not like the
super
super I hate that why you don't give me
this joke of a food give me something
real give me something tangible like
what like more cake less cream like what
give an example what's a what's a cake
that's better than Strawberry Short Cake
um [__] what's a cake well first of all
if if you know on the top on there I
always put tons of cream on it I always
just scrape it off you know my problem
with cakes my problem with cakes and
pretty much every heavy
dessert it's like it's great it tastes
great but it takes up valuable stomach
space of like what I could be eating in
like a main course for like lunch that's
what I'm thinking that's what I'm
thinking it's it's like there is never a
point they like I've eaten [__] great
cakes before but it's always hampered my
enjoyment of the following lunch or
dinner and I [__] hate that well
that's why I think when it comes to
Strawberry Shortcakes I'd rather just
eat it as kind of like a snack type of
thing or like like kind of a dessert but
like way after the main meal okay you
know like like strawberry shortcake to
me is kind of those things where like
you go out to dinner right at some
restaurant and then on the way home you
see like a strawberry shortcake slice
being sold and you take that home and
then you eat it at home type that's what
I like who the [__] started birthday
cakes I just I just hate them birthday
cakes yeah cuz it's like every [__]
birthday there's got to be a cake and
I'm like man it's just like I don't like
cakes much you know the worst part about
cakes we do a birthday terisu you know
come we just do that like do you know do
you know the worst part about cakes
especially if you buy a whole one aside
from like everything fond it's it's like
this is this is why I don't raise don't
rate cakes right you go to a birthday
party or a wedding or something right
they bring out the cakes right and it's
always this moment of how many people
want to eat the cake and guaranteed half
of the room are I don't want eat the
cake just like eating it out of
obligation not because they actually
want the cake or like craving the cake
but they always just like have a few
bites out of like obligation and then
there's always [__] leftovers and
then they're like you have to eat it I'm
like okay fine can you come in a small
slice and they come s who what the [__]
is this it's like [__] you trying to
do a trigonometry example here what the
[__] is this see and I think that's why
Japan is kind of nailed in that aspect
of the fact that they yeah obviously
they sell whole Cakes as well but a lot
of cake places in Japan they sell it as
like single actual like edible sized
slices the ones that you can just like
kind of pick up and eat oh my favorite
cake pound cake or banana banana bread
me me pancake good pan so to me that
like defeats the point of the cake cuz
the cake is like symbolic of like some
kind of like celebration you know is it
yeah for me I really don't I'll never
eat cake out of a celebration outside of
a celebration just yeah yeah yeah like
to me like the cake is symbolic and with
Japan stting in like small slices I'm
like you have removed the one thing that
I will agree with about cakes which is
like the symbolic meaning of cakes cuz
but Japan also made Colonel Sanders
Santa so you can't believe anything
they're doing they just [__] around
like to me there is nothing more like
basic tradition there's nothing more
depressing than like seeing like you
know the candles on like a single slice
of cake you know what I mean who's doing
that you know you see you see it
sometimes especially like Japan is the
one place where you can actually do that
because they buy with slices when people
bring me a cake for my birthday and I'm
like I'm not eating that I I hate to
break it to you I I just don't like cake
that all right for your birthday next
year I'm bring your yeah bring me a with
the candle do that that's way better
that's like an a superior cake all right
can we just skip to the spag the spag
ball SP
ball Joey why would you pick I put spag
ball on here because this is a dish that
my grandma used to make me when I was
little and I have very very good fun
memories of making this with my grandma
Yeah but you sorry sorry to bring a so
story into it you still order this at a
restaurant Joey sometimes yeah this is
like actually I got a spag ball two days
ago this is the reason why Hershey is
popular cuz it was [__] in the they
used to eat it like listen you're you're
being clouded now am saying am I saying
am I saying this is the best pasta dish
no but I have the most Fondest Memories
ofor I don't he about your memories tell
me what you think huh I I don't care a
[__] about your memories tell me what
you think is the best the best I think
is the chicken genov pesta that's good
that's good yeah good with P that is
easily the best pasta but that's also
[__] boring is it no it's not boring
no it's not boring you know what's you
know what's boring spaghetti B that's
Bor you know what's not boring my great
memories love spaghetti
bolog you know what boring your grandma
wow it was her birthday
yesterday she have bolog no you cake as
well Joey NOP she said she was going to
make spag ball when I got home and I was
very excited I would stay back in Japan
if I heard that I don't want to go give
me a real meal
youing 94y old grandma Jo if I can grow
up from McDonald's you can grow up from
spag ball okay grow up grow up Grandma
Joey never how dare you what are you
doing wake up wake up
she we deserve
better all right you should have said
you know you can you can still cook
bolock just use a different pasta that
that doesn't detract from you do better
does B work with other pastas yeah of
course it does it it definitely does you
think yeah yeah with pen it's better
with pen that's true oh what's the
butterfly ones the butterfly bow TI the
bow tie on those are pretty I've had
those as well with bise yeah even with
um [__] it's like the most common one
what the [__] it's like spaghetti feels
flattened I like is no Ling is it
Linguini Linguini is the uh terrible
sorry Italian I'm so sorry Italians
Linguini is like spaghetti with a little
bit more bite
far that's the bow tie one yeah what's
the what's the what's the no what's the
hold we got
here Linguini is not fetuccini is it
fetuccini yeah
fetuccini oh yeah yeah yeah the flat one
f is like better spaghetti it's like
this is like way better than spaghetti
it absorbs and holds the flavor there's
more surface area hold the flavor more
yeah yeah flat earthers are right when
it comes to like past because like there
is there is like the flatness just holds
the flavor way better fedini alfredo
that's right that makes sense now
right okay I like I just like the B
sauce I think I like
papelli Papi P right um what what what
next uh Su man understandable suan
understandable we don't have to talk
about we've talked about I changed your
guys' mind by take to the skim place
it's fine gentleman handshake agreement
gentle hand goed take a producer to Sig
as well yeah yeah yeah I we took out I
took my producer and his girlfriend to
the skim in place and uh and he came
back to me he late I had dreams of that
place like yes all right cool cool all
right kangar sausage this is another one
that I think is the best type of sausage
you could have Australians will agree
with me on this uh you can buy this at a
supermarket Kanger bangers as we call
them I would like to they're great next
time you guys are in Australia you
should try some Kang I want to try these
so I can talk [__] in the correct way
I'm just speculating right now I just
don't believe it taste better than
European sausage I think you'll like
them I think you'll like them a lot
proba like I mean they look great is
that is that how an a kangaroo sausage
looks uh yeah I guess it has the correct
girth of a sausage that I enjoy yeah no
it's it's a proper it looks like a
sausage you know itly looks like a now
gone Let's It come on now that's you're
being Panic
now that that there is a look of a
sausage and that looks like it will
taste good that looks like it has a
fantastic snap which is an important
part of any sausage they and also looks
like it has the right amount of girth
going on so you can cut it up and get
juiciness as well is on point really I I
like the thin sausages well you're a
fool of G so I don't know how to tell
you that uh the thicker sausages are
better I I don't know the ones where you
have to cut with a [__] knife and
fork not the ones where you can just
[__] shov generally thinner sausages
uh line up more to like the processed
kind of yeah hot dog style you can you
can definitely get like obviously like
obviously thick sausages are more
readily available uh when it comes to
you know proper sausages I just it's
okay it's it's kind of like too much
meat can't can't handle the meat is what
you're saying I think it just goes back
to like the wrapping the skin you know
it's it's just like like that's the best
part of the sausage that's the best part
of the sausage sorry the skin is the
best part the when the skin snaps when
you buite into it that's the best part
I'm I'm saying you get more of that with
like the thin sausages because there's
less meat in there do you no no you
don't unless you cook the [__] out of
this thing until it's like crispy on the
outside I don't know like whenever I've
gone to whenever whenever I've gone to
the supermarket and I see like the
million different flavors of like the
thick sausages and sometimes I just see
the thin sausage and I'm like I I wish
there was more flavors for the thin
sausages in the the thicker ones right
it needs more pressure more power to
contain all that meat so it has a
greater snap when it's broken uh and I
and then the juice spurts out and you
get
that very passionate about sausages um
he's a JoJo why kangaroos though yeah
kangaroos I just okay so it the like the
thing I like about kangaroo meat in
general um that I think I just prefer it
over beef I want to try it uh is that I
think it's pork sausages is the gold
standard by way yeah pork is by far the
best but I I really I I put kangaroo
sausages almost on the same level as
pork sausages is like I think they have
all of the same qualities of a pork
sausage but is a little bit more tender
than a beef sausage if that makes sense
so awful though yeah beef sausages
aren't that great I feel like the the
some beef sausages Pork yeah pork is by
far the best but I think kangar is a
very very close second if not tied first
sausage so it's very yeah when we're in
Australia we'll get you some all right
what the [__] natto come on Nat is I
mean it is the superfood that I could
eat every [__] day look at me okay I
I'll accept Nat but like you can't look
at me and tell me that Nat top n foods
of all time better than American
barbecue better than pizza better than
uh no way Indian food Italian we're
talking about breakfast foods that's the
king of breakfast foods right there BR
you're delusional delal on a bed of rice
also Nat can be used in all sorts of
different dude Nat and Curry is Bon okay
okay you're delusional amazing Nat in a
sushi form amazing explain to me this
okay explain to me this all right I've
had Nat we've all had Nat
fine with the flavor of Nat and
everything I mean he's not but yeah all
right all right but food texture is
important right bad texture texture is
important right texture is import so
important sell me on a food that has the
same texture profile as fleem just like
just like just just just explain how you
mentally get does it does it have the
texture of flam it also looks like flam
look at that
picture that is like a going to say it I
don't give a [__] about the texture of
food that's crazy to me that's crazy I
literally do not care about the texture
of you just backing me up on the
snap I'll eat baby food if I have to I
don't give a [__] as long as it tastes
good I don't care
text also to me here's the other thing
as well also to me it's kind of we're
not even standing at the same starting
line because this is a texture to me
that's not weird because I've had it all
my goddamn life right so obviously you
guys are going to think texture is
important because there are some
textures out there in food Cuisines
which are just out of the norm for you
guys to me Nat is a very normal texture
to me but you you're also arguing that
texture isn't important no it's not
something I'm going to be like uh this
is disgusting like I've had so I've
literally had all sorts of different
like you know sticky you know slimy
whatever [__] growing up that to me that
texture is noral texture is massively
important texture like texture sometimes
you you get I believe this that's just a
weak mindset if you ask me I can't
believe that this is top sometimes it is
as important as the taste I was like
trying trying to like weak mindset it's
it's okay okay have you ever had for
example soggy Fried Chicken you know
fried chicken that's been out too long
and it just doesn't have that same like
crispiness to it it tastes the same but
you heat up in the microwave [__]
tastes awful like eat it it just like
it's just it's well I've been a broke
college student before I'm not going to
pick and choose this [__] even as I get
that but I would never have Fried
Chicken like I'll never have it over the
[__] fresh [__] obviously yeah but
what I'm saying is is that like this
whole idea of the the sticky flamy
texture being like you know the end all
be all of everything in terms of food I
think is just a weak mindset I think I
have a weak mindset it's enough to
discourage me uh fair enough uh
watermelon um best fruit arguably well I
I hate disagreeing with everything but
yeah I disagree
juste uh it's the it's it's the best
fruit because you get the most out of
your bang for buck like you get a giant
[__] watermelon you get so much out
of that it is it is watery so you know
you can hydrate yourself at the same
time right melon is just better in every
way melon sometimes has just too much
flavor what the melons also melon can
get some sometimes melon can get a bit
soggy oh and watermelon can't
no watermelon is like it is I think what
is the makeup of watermelon it's like 99
like something [__] water that's what
what good it's it's basically like it's
like when you you know when you have
like uh the the drinks where you like
concentrate and you add water it's like
that if you like someone spat some of
the concentrate into a glass and then
you put 2 lers of water you're like I
have it D the fresh watermelon juice 92%
water 92% the fresh watermelon juice I
had in Thailand like confirmed to me
that watermelon is the best I would say
the watermelon is definitely top tier
it's a top tier for I disag 100% in the
summer as
well watermelon it's better than banana
it's way better B it is way better than
banana kid me not even in the same what
the [__] are we talking about here let's
be let's be reasonable at all here come
on banana banana overrated are you
kidding me I'm not kidding you like
banana it's like I don't dislike banana
like you know I don't have like every
dislike for banana it's it's good I I I
enjoy it it's it's I'll eat it yeah what
the [__] are you guys talking about I'll
e it it's not my first nor fifth choice
you guys are delusional the Banana's
kind of like the my here Academia fruit
what the I won't stand no I won't stand
for that com you need to take that
comment back like my opinion my hero
Academia watermelon is like the monster
of you are insulting my entire being
right now you cannot say that it's just
like safe it has this like good it's
okay huh everybody likes it it's good
for any occasion but is it the best out
there no no watermelon certainly is not
banana Leaps and Bounds ahead of the
watermelon it actually has flavor it
doesn't crumble into water in your mouth
after one bite that's what I love about
it why why you got to have [__] seeds
in there bro what an annoyance [__]
seeds get the seedless ones yeah
watermelon yeah watermelon more like you
know a tack on Titan you know it's it's
like they're [__] bloated and goes on
for too long you know you know compared
to like some you know it's still very
very popular but you don't see it around
as often as like you know the mainstream
kind of fruits like [__] bananas
apples watermelon watermelon be laying
low in the winter but when the summer H
oh my God it is the star of the show The
the beta seasonal Fruit versus the Chad
allrounder the Bas perfect portion ready
for any occasion always the right am
more nutritional value it's better in
every single way like the thing the
thing looks like a [__] you know you
know like it's not just the fruit it's
not just the fruit but you know if you
have like messy you you know if you have
like a watermelon like sweet you know
it's going to [__] watermelon
flavored things trumps banana flavored
things any day any day of the week any
day of the [__] week go back to your
natto Strawberry Shortcake bollocks [__]
off I don't delicious I would stand for
this the only thing that keeps
watermelon from being like the perfect
perfect fruit is the seeds that's like
that's like the only thing and FL and
the lack of flavor I I was okay there
there's two things it's just like there
are different like tears it's like you
it's like you have like the sweet Center
which is like [__] Godlike and then
you get close to like the crust and it
starts to become a little more like
flavorless as you get closer to the edge
and you just have to like take that L
only only in the watermelon context that
I will be uh cross
gang with with G uh you know when
whenever I have watermelon whenever I
buy like a big watermelon during the
summer I don't even do like the [__]
triangular [__] like that like I cut it
up into blocks so that I can just get
rid of all the crust immediately and I
can I'm just left with the good [__]
yeah not every bite of watermelon is the
same when it comes to like especially
you get close to the edge it gets bit
little tougher a little uh less uh D you
put that [__] in the freezer let it sit
for a little bit on a really hot summer
day and you crack that [__] open God
damn but bu what can I say watermelon
still a top tier fruit top tier fruit
best fruit in I would agree with you
Joey banana not all right all right Mis
soou very safe very safe option yeah
this is comfort food for me I mean you
know growing up in a Japanese household
this is like a type of thing which is
super easy to make uh you know very
versatile you can put anything inside
miso soup and most of the time it works
very very well you know this one has
leak and uh tofu in it but like you know
you can put uh carrot steak on onion um
seaweed you know anything goes like
there's there's a ton of different
things you can put in it and white or
red miso ooh see when I was growing up
in sandai we had white miso yeah uh but
I do like red miso as well I like red
miso more red miso is good more
intensity more flavor yeah I agree with
that but is a good comfort food I I'll
let you have that one yeah and also
great for hangovers best thing to have
for hangovers great in general just
great in general you want a warm up if
you're sick you're hung over you just
want something you know to fill yourself
up for a little bit m I just can't think
of a situation where I wouldn't think
it's acceptable yeah like I I honestly
think miso s has that power where it
just like transcends Cuisines I would
you know I would love to have miso soup
in like any kind of Cuisine you know I
I'm trying to think any I'm trying to
think of a starter like a Cuisine where
it wouldn't work as a starter and would
yeah I of works with everything yeah uh
you have suaki suaki yeah that's my
favorite hot pot memories of you know me
and the family eating it once a year it
is the best hot pot of all the Japanese
hot is the best hot pot give me give me
Chinese hot pot Chinese hot pot to me is
is is superior I I was this close to
putting Chinese hot pot on my 3x3
actually I like Chinese hot poot butaki
I like suyaki Mo I think yeah there's a
different level ofak is too clean
there's a different level of comfort and
balance yeah n Chinese hotot has like
has all of those [__] h and the
flavor and it's just so strong and the
[__] meat just soaks up like the the
Sukiyaki soup is just too it's it's not
flavorful enough you know cuz one one
part I love about like the hot pots is
just putting a bunch of [__] in it and
having whatever ingredients you put in
it just soak up that flavor and to me
Chinese hot pot because the soup is way
like to me like thicker um and more
flavorful it just you can taste it so
much more in the ingredients you put in
m and Suki yucky yeah it's a little bit
cleaner definitely you you come out of
it not hating your body yeah which is I
guess like B big thing but to me given
the choice okay do I want to be health
conscious or do I want to eat something
that [__] slaps and Destro Shak is
healthy at all is it not healthy at all
no I mean it's a lot of soy sauce loads
of soy sauce so it's very very salty
yeah uh I mean the ingredient healthier
in comparison yeah the ingredients you
throw in are definitely more healthier
than otherwise but I wouldn't neily say
chines hot has like way more oils in it
uh oh yeah so yeah yeah I mean like this
is one thing where like I'll always have
a craving for it like this is one of
those things where like I love it it's
one of my favorite Japanese foods but
it's one of those Japanese Foods where
like I only want to eat it maybe like
two or three times a year and nothing
more cuz like if I have it more often
than that I feel the magic of it is
going to disappear and I'm very happy
with it being like a thing where it's
just happens you know once every happen
stance and when that happens dance
happens you're just like hell yeah I I
[__] deserve this this is goated
especially this time of year it's yucky
goated uh the last one is chicken paos
so this is my favorite Hungarian food
look uh that my again my favorite thing
that my grandma used to make uh it's
basically uh chicken thigh and chicken
wing uh in a paprika sauce with uh this
thing called nedly uh which is kind of
like I don't know how to explain y it's
kind of like uh halfway between past
and bread okay it's the only way to H it
looks [__] incredible it is so good
it really really really good and I
really want to learn how to make this um
but yeah this is another one where like
if I would go to every time I go to my
Grandma's place she'd either make me
spaghetti Bales or chicken poh and those
are the only two things I ever asked
half the time she's [__] doing you
dirty like be I come on hey man chicken
po cost takes a long time no there's no
shot I'm taking the spaghetti over there
are you kidding me what the [__] yeah
like I I was craving this so much during
uh the pandemic obviously cuz I couldn't
go see my grandma that uh I was looking
up like Hungarian restaurants in Tokyo I
found one one Hungarian restaurant in
Tokyo and they had chicken poosh it was
good but I was like damn like Grandma
magic is a real thing oh yeah yeah and
it's just not the same I don't know I
don't know what the difference was but
it just didn't taste the same have you
ever tried learning the dish my sisters
learned how to to make it and she's
gotten better at it uh I this is like
one thing I mean I don't really care
about she doesn't have the grandma buff
she you just shees have the grandma she
okay so like my grandma actually wrote
the recipe for this but the way she
wrote it was the most Easter Old Eastern
European woman way of riding look to the
East and grab the spice you seek no no
she said like get the paprika at a good
amount and I'm like what what's a good
amount how you know it's fire it's like
you know it's the good amount yeah but
like she just knows the thing about
ingredients like like recipes like this
cuz I've had similar instances with my
mom where I've craved some of her
cooking and she's tried to like walk me
through step by step somehow I [__] it
up somewhere yeah I like I don't know
how this is possible cuz I've literally
had her on a zoom call I'm like Mom how'
you how' you make your Curry and she's
like all right let me walk you through
step by step tastes different and
doesn't like somehow where she's like I
I don't even know if she knows how much
she puts in she just like it's it's like
Ultra Instinct you know it's just like
she knows the right amount of
ingredients and when I start measuring
[__] that's how I know it's not going to
be as good totally yeah okay yeah so
that's mine 3x3 agree with some I don't
agree with yeah fair enough I feel
that's going to be the case with all of
our three middle row I don't agree with
no [__] you watermelon is the best dog I
don't all right let's see
con real all right don't don't yeah
don't show you don't show you don't show
it so you've played your games boys
you've had your cute little list time to
show you what a real you've talked your
talk let's see real three looks like let
me show you this let me show you this
all right we got some bangers there we
go that at that that's a list what a
[__] list all right all right all
right
all just to confirm tell me your British
without telling me your just to confirm
uh this is a list of foods right yeah
what is that what is beer doing there
beer is a food in [__] Germany Conor
oh beer beer is food not a food food I
drink beer as a food substitute it's
it's liquid bread yeah it's it's it's
food how is it not food sorry I mean
it's like 300 calories carbs a drink
it's it's carbonated it's nice food you
drink it yeah but I yeah but you can
drink some you drink miso is that it
okay hold on that's the least of my
worries there's this other
You' done me dirty with this beans and
toast picture you [__] I I didn't get
these pictures that is the worst picture
of beans and toast gave my list to the
producers and they gave me the sloppiest
saddest looking beans on toast I've ever
seen in my life okay so we got McCoy's
chips listen right uh crisps actually
chips they're [__] chips what are you
[__] talking about they're chips I
don't I don't believe this crisp look at
your flag and remind remind yourself who
you are all right you belong to us okay
so those are crisps uh these are
specifically McCoy crisp these are
bangers there's not a single occasion
where if offered to me I will I will say
no to these they're just so godamn they
are the thing about McCoy that other
Chris need to take a lesson from is that
not only is the texture Godlike the
crunch is immaculate but they are I'm
just looking at this and I'm just like
this is so British tell me you're
British without telling you're British
it is absolutely packed with flavor each
bite of McCoy over flavored honestly
quite frankly there's so much green and
brown in this thir I love I love my
green I love my brown um uh and I you
know I thought about you know honestly
your favorite McCoy flavor oh it's so
tough but I think the cheddar and onion
is the [__] God flame steak is pretty
good too I love I love the and also the
salt and vinegar listen CU sometimes a
British tradition uh CU you know in
America right you get a bag of Cris
crisps right they're too big they're
like they are they are commitments in
the UK we've kind of we've got we've
perfected the size of the crisp bag cuz
you can have one you can feel like I'm
good but you can also be like I'm going
to have three bags is it healthy no but
I would regularly just eat all three
flavors well the good thing about McCoy
is that I believe it's all crinkle cup
right all crinkle the superior the
superior it is the superior crisp and
it's a bit it's a bit thicker than like
Walkers max if you go to the UK please
try McCoy they are [__] I was
converted I I love McCoy as well McCoy
are great I totally agree with that I
honestly like The McCoys could be a part
of the the meal deal at the bottom cuz
it's kind of they kind of they go hand
in hand cuz I I really wanted to put
Indian food on here but I didn't know
which Indian food specifically I was
debating to put Indian curry but but I I
don't have a favorite if you put a gun
in my head it' be mutton Curry but
mutton Curry is so it's it could be
whatever spices you put in it yeah for
me it's tie between mutton and Kema and
I and I and I feel like I can't just put
a cuisine on there cuz that's not fair
you know cuz that's like saying like you
didn't put you wanted to put barbecue
but you pick ribs right I can't do that
with Indian food I love Indian food so
much I couldn't pick one but McCoy man I
mean sometimes you we're sleeping on
snacks in our 3x3 is what I'm realizing
no none of you guys put snacks down I I
actually had a snack on there and I took
it off what did you have on there you
you guys would like the reason I took it
off is cuz I don't think anyone would
have heard of it um there's this like
Thai fish snack okay called tle you told
me about this yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
it's it's kind of like it's available in
Japan as well uh she's called something
different but it's like also like a
little bit spicy as well I I would have
put Red Rock Deli chips uh which I still
think are the best CH potato chips out
there only in Australia though but I put
Easter eggs that's give me them when I'm
there that's a snack to me Easter eggs
Easter eggs I think it's it's too easy
to look at meals and think main meal of
dinner right you put you put some
breakfast ones and you put some dessert
there and I I wanted to make sure I was
getting a variation of snacks in there
too so that's fine that's why I you went
so far that you put an alcoholic
beverage as well
beer is food you can't change my mind uh
none of this you know I think you know
is it the best alcohol uh yes 100% 100%
100% for me beer is the best alcohol uh
I used to think that but I don't think I
think that anymore I think I think you
know I roll my eyes when I when I go to
places in America and they're like we
have like skull [__] IPA which is
they'll call it that or they'll call it
like bum scratch IPA you're like what
the [__] is this [__] it's like an 8% Al
be you're like what the [__] is this
just give me a give me something good
give me like
a close to being the perfect alcohol if
it didn't have the [__] calorie
content yeah well I you know labels bro
as I mentioned I I I do as I mentioned I
do enjoy alcohol-free beer I this the
one in Japan they do they do no calorie
no carbs alcohol-free beer and it tastes
it scratches that at your beer it's
fantastic but it's notot of food um
normal beer is food yeah liquid bread I
agree beer is food uh you can't have
that as a meal you you can't have that
as a meal you most certainly can okay
gone all I've had a few nights where
I've only had a beer and I went home
full yeah I've had I've had that was a
mistake it was a mistake but I still
went home I've had evenings where I've
you know just been like all right I'm I
have the beer and I'm kind of bloated
and I'm like I'm kind of good yeah I'll
just keep drinking
beer that's like should I no but I do
yeah not often do I do that game's game
uh beer is food you can't change your
mind I was I was about to make an
argument and then I realized it's was
going to be a really hot take go on
coward you won't okay okay I can't I
can't have just soup as a meal either uh
if you if you just give me liquid as a
meal it's that's like not a meal to me
beer is better than soup uh I would
agree with you except I could easily
just have miso soup not as a meal no you
can't have miso soup just be like okay
alol alcohol
is alcohol is considered a food item
because it supplies your bodies with
calories
SE crayons uh no cray cray they don't
have that much they don't have enough
calories no you can you can you can have
like a th000 calories of beer easily so
any drink with calories is Count counts
as food no it's not it's not so water is
not food it's got like carbs in it as
well you know don't don't give me this
[__] this is like the same this is like
the same [__] where
like do sandwich well technically it's
like two piece it's like no just don't f
drink look the important thing is the
important thing is if I order a [__]
meal and all you give me is [__] beer
I'm going to be like yo where the food
where the food at I'll get some little
snackies with it but the beer is the
main food yeah usually The McCoys pairs
yeah the mcco with the be that's they
they go hand in hand often um so yeah
beer I I I recognize as food and I love
love beer a lot um and then in the
middle which is not a great photo I
really uh not the middle sorry the mid
top middle it's not a great you notaki
it's shaki but it looks kind of bad no I
recognize the sh that's like Denise
sh that is not a flattering looking that
is a very midl looking that is what the
average sh looks like that is what it
looks like what the tomatoes on the side
you don't normally get tomatoes on the
side so you want to defend this because
I like it but I like it but it's not my
favorite what I think that that is what
I think of which is like dude you
got I think of like the [__] knco 400
and Shak no there's some places that do
it so [__] good shaki is um just kind
of like ginger pork Ginger pork it's
like Grilled Ginger pork and uh it's
just great if you have like good quality
pork and you you have some really thick
sauce goes so well with rice my problem
with shog Yaki is kind of what this
picture is it's like a lot of the times
it just looks depressing I don't I don't
want this GRE look look at look at that
look at that picture the only thing that
out depresses that picture is the beans
on toast you know favorite sugar yakis
was the one that that uh mat used to do
before they changed the recipe [__]
uh they made their pork worse for some
reason and uh used to be great so like
the type in like matsa shaki probably
because probably because people weren't
[__] going to matsa to get sh going
there to get they were they were being
cucked and they changed the menu uh it's
this amazing like Comfort traditional
Japanese food you've got to try it it's
[__] god tier look at that pck I mean
yeah like for me that's not that's not
sure uh mat shogayaki which one is it
probably the left one right um the very
the very right one looks more similar to
it I mean look the left one yeah shaki
for sure is great it's it's amazing
comfort food for God it looks so bad but
it tastes so good it does taste out of
out of the you know incredibly visually
you know appealing Japanese foods that
exist out there this one is definitely
not I was wondering how they [__] up
presenting show like Japanese are like
the Masters present make that look good
listen the thing is like Jo I love it
Ramen I love it but when I think about
like something that makes you feel good
inside shogayaki just does something to
me I was very close to putting goer on
my
3x3 I had G and I took it off as well um
you know I just think of all the
Japanese foods that really gives me a
sense of comfort and this is one of them
um it's just such a good whole uh eating
experience and if you come to Japan I
really recommend trying it it's not
thought about as one of the great
Japanese Foods um it never gets get love
but it's
you know one Japanese side dish that I
[__] hate that you can see on that
shogo Yaki dish the Cabbage it's the
[__] really thinly sliced cabbage
it's
like I hate it yeah yeah it is it is
often it kind of makes me feel like a
horse eating hay you know it has it has
negative flavor it is it is always the
worst like I'm cheting that [__]
forever every time I see this on a plate
I'm like you had empty space in the
plate and you did not know how to fill
up that space unless there is like a
banger dressing when you go to like some
Catu places but I hate it I hate it they
call it salad as well it's this is not a
salad it is not a salad salad requires
multiple elements involved you know what
I mean so like yeah but the only time I
actually like that is when you have
katsu on cuz you catsu CU you need you
need something to chill out the [__]
oil sure and it kind of works but um
yeah I mean it's one one that I would
recommend is it the best food ever uh no
but it's it's definitely a huge compat
food oh yeah for sure it's up there
let's talk about something that is the
best food ever right now danish hot dogs
hot dogs in general well that's a Danish
hot dog that is a Danish hot dog which
is is a god tier hot dog which is the
best the best hot dog the only hot dogs
I love all dogs right I love all types
of dogs you know you can get like uh
German style right you can get more
British style hot dogs which are
typically just really thick sausages
that are smaller like in length I don't
really count British like sausages well
they're in like the hot they're they're
in a bun it's a sausage in a bun it has
sauce in it it's a hot dog uh whether
you like it or not that is true um the
traditional hot dog that we all we all
familiar as the American one they are
they have cockroaches in them probably
hairs who knows what else rat feces
probably something else but man does it
tastes good I [__] love it even like
going to like a ball game which I don't
do why why' you like it I just [__]
love it you know what I'm going to say
it I genuinely do not like those kinds
of hot dogs I love those [__] dogs I
just think hot dogs from like aside from
like the danger shot dogs I just think
they're [__] overrated yeah I I okay
chili dogs I [__] chili dogs CH dogs
areed CH dogs are regular hot dogs are
boring chili dogs are great not because
of the hot dog because because of the
chili you know it's it's it's part and
it's part of the texture which one
earlier it's part of the snap I love the
bread and I love the the bread to Sauce
to meat ratio it's perfect I really like
you know saus
onions I used to think hot dogs would
just eight cuz in my mind I was only
thinking about the American hot dogs and
then we had the Danish hot dogs on
tour there's different levels of quality
that you can get but I love all dogs I
want all dogs in my mouth regardless of
quality um you know I just want them all
pa um I like yeah I I admit the Danish
hot dog probably Superior to most hot
dog do you prefer a hot dog over like
just a traditional sausage in a bun most
of the times yeah I like cuz I like the
bread aspect I like the I like the sauce
aspect um f that from a like a [__]
real sausage I mean don't get me wrong
don't get me wrong sausages would be on
this list too but I can't have two
sausages on the list me saying the
sausage sandwich is better than I love
again sausage sandwiches British sausage
buddies no no you guys [__] it up but
the Australians did it the correct way
you talking about yeah you guys cut that
[__] in half that from us yeah we made
it better you guys cut that [__] in half
and you put two slices of bread that's
too much bread get one slice of bread
diagonally wrap that [__] around you can
hold in one hand you get full sausage we
do it better no no cuz you're we do it
it's just cuz you can't in Australia you
you can't afford more bread actually we
don't want more bread we want more
sausage you you guys
fin speaking my language speak silence
bread I don't it doesn't matter if you
validate him here if you a British
sausage sandwich is also one of my
favorite comt foods as well just sausage
with bread regardless of which
combination it's being put in is is my
probably my favorite food of all time
it's up there it's my number one thing I
will never ever say no to a hot dog or a
British sausage sandwich or a sausage on
its own I just love sausage I hands out
right I'm a JoJo fan I want sausage in
every single form but I can never like
not think that hot dog like every time
I've had a hot dog that's an American
hot dog not D hot dogs uh I just can
never I can just never not think I would
just prefer a real sausage 100% yeah but
if I'm in the occasion I'm like I'm down
the snap is there that's all I'm looking
for the snap the sauce the bread the
quality it tastes so [__] processed
yeah it is it does it does and it's it's
definitely not as good but it's like
it's like eating pickles too oh it's
it's like you know having the choice of
like a steak or something and being like
actually I would rather have spam you
know okay well I now if we're talking
like American like street food stuff
like you know like say like you know if
you're in New York or something right
there's tons of like food stands hot dog
included I'd rather just get a [__]
Kebab w w w any day of the week hot
Kebab Oro any day of the
week better no it's not it's I've had
the I've had hot dogs from New York like
you know food stands before and it
they're just all right the [__]
kebabs and Euros though [__] when when I
tour America I tried every style of
American hot dog as well and they were
all fantastic all the Tony dogs uh the
Ben chili bow dogs in DC that was an
amazing spot you know they got the
Chicago Dogs no Source I respect the
hosle up for and then you were all
trumped by uh Denmark so Denmark also
great every I love every form of so I
think it's fine um speaking of Joey who
called me basic genoves Pastor is my
favorite Pastor I pick one y Pi one over
spaghetti Bales it would be this one I
do like that we've all put a different
type of pasta on here although I am
noticing that's spaghetti I believe I
think that's is that not Linguini that
looks like Linguini that's
lingu spaghetti come on Joey the
difference between your Linguini and
your spaghetti what are you doing uh
Linguini is okay but I obviously would
prefer anything else the thing I like
about uh the thing I really really like
about gen is it geneves as a source is
strong enough that on its own it can
just carry yeah but you can add stuff to
it to make it if you want to you know
fatten up a little bit you can add
shrimp to it you can add uh some kind of
veg to it you can add you can you can
add meat you want broccolini or
asparagus oh it's so good it's just so
it just Nails it dude and it's such an
intense flavor and no other Pastor comes
close to tasting like it it's such a
unique flavor for sure yeah cuz they
they were just like what if basil was
everything and we were like all right
let's hear the guy out Pesto's goed pest
is go I'm a pesto is god tier I'm a
fiend for pest I literally went to goova
just to
have just because I was like I love this
food so much I want to go to the source
uh and it was amazing I went to the
source baby source of thece it was so
worth it I everywhere they had lasagna
that was uh genoves base and it was
insane it was so good it was that sounds
like my dream dish it was amazing you've
just improved on uh gen they had pasta
that was infused with uh geneves uh or
like pesto so that it was like well [__]
I know what I'm getting for dinner
tonight dude I'm telling you like they
it is such an amazing Bish yeah and I
just love it uh but I you know what when
I go to a lot of Italian restaurants I
normally I I don't order it all the time
I'm very reserved with how I want to
order it I'm especially in Japan I feel
like they don't do it justice here um
they don't go hard enough with the with
the pesto they they Reserve they hold
back M they treat it like it's a Peppa
pepperon Chino or something they they
they do it like a light flavor like no
you got to bury it I respect nunciation
of that
yeah it's like it's a lighter pasture
Japan Japan likes their lighter pastures
and I I feel like Japanese hate their
flavor they just hate flavor right and I
feel like when they do a pesto pasta
here right uh when they just they too
scared to pile it on I agree yeah bury
it if it doesn't look like this if it
doesn't look this green you haven't put
enough on totally totally in Japan
they'll it'll be like a light green I'm
like what is this use spaghetti as well
it's [__] always spaghetti here I
hate Japan it's like spinning on the
Mona Lisa I'm like why why would you do
that the only spaghetti it's already a
work of art Italians are crying yeah so
you go to a nice you go to a real
Italian place here and they'll be like
what kind of pasta do you want you're
like my heroes they're asking me what
kind of fresh Pastor I want I get very
passionate about this cuz I think that
spaghetti tells me you didn't try yeah
it tells me you thought about Pastor as
a monolith you thought about it as all
being accessible from the view of
spaghetti and I hate that uh so yeah all
right now I realized now I'm going to
have to put the Tesco sandwich oh okay I
thought we going to the beans on toast I
was going have to yeah do beans on toast
first I got to start defending all right
all right defend whatever the this this
picture has done it fck as as a bastard
you you bastard this is the worst
picture ever as a fellow Brit okay as a
fellow Brit how do you present beans on
toast and not make it look like the most
depressing dish you so so uh first of
all um I I I I understand there is a
barrier of Entry to to beans on toast
that is liking beans cuz some people
just do not like beans and I I can
understand that I'm a big bean lover
yeah um so the way that you make beans
on I would never eat it like this the
way you make beans on toast God to take
it to another level first of all white
bread get rid of it we need we need
better bread than this you can get like
like seated bread you get seated bread
you can get brown bread multi-grain
bread you know get bread with more
flavor more starch that compliments the
beans better white bread gets way too
soggy too quick and becomes mush so you
get the the nicer bread you toast the
bread it's got to be toast like I know I
know but some people don't do enough
they're too scared
to that raw that is bread not toasted
enough there you got to toast it a
little there should be a little bit of
the bread that is slightly like charred
right then this is where you take it to
the next level put cheddar on it you you
got to put cheese on it you put cheese
you can slice the cheese put it on top
and then take it to the next level you
put it in the you put it in the right
you let the cheese melt that's that's
what that's what everyone who doesn't
eat live in England that's this is the
image people think I never heard of the
cheese so so then you so then you so
bear in mind you toast the bread
independently you get the beans ready
put it on top you put the cheese that's
not it's just blocks of cheese right
then you put it in the oven the cheese
melts you take it out you fry an egg so
it's a fried egg on top god tier and
then you can put which I like doing but
it's not for everyone you can put the HP
sauce on it which is like a British
staple brown sauce yeah brown sauce and
then you've got an absolute gig chat of
a meal sounds it's so good it's cheese
egg beans and bread and it's like a mush
I know people I feel like at this point
so good it's beyond you can't even call
that beans on toast anymore but that's
how you make beans on toast like that's
just like a breakfast toast it's so
[__] I I don't know I mean I you know
there's an aspect of comfort in this
I'll admit TR I mean I I ate [__] you
know Hines beans when I was growing up
as well cuz that was all over Australia
but like mean I'm not going to argue
this because I'm not American you know
so I know the Americans want to come for
me and they tell me that I'm clowning
maybe if there was an American on this
podcast this would be a much more
controversial pick I will say the one
Collective memory everyone has with like
you know unloading a can of beans onto
bread is that doesn't matter how big the
bread is that shit's always falling off
that shit's always spilling over it
needs to spill it needs to Spill the
ratio needs to be more Americans are too
afraid to try this they they fear for
what they don't know uh you know they
they need well the one you you said
actually sounds really [__] good dude
it's so good I need to try that now
for me I have a bigger problem with
tusk's meal deal you put that over gra
really well the gra could be up here
this is you know what honestly the Gregs
probably deserves the spot more I'll be
I'll be real with you the Gregs does
deserve it but I had to rep it I had to
rep it and Nostalgia but that you know
what they've got to be fair the Chicken
Club Banger chicken club's good I also
like the stuffing bacon and chicken uh
one is really good too although I
overate I say bacon is kind of mid but
the stuffing is really good um I I do
think that tesos have gotten way too
comfortable jacking up those prices it's
getting to the point now where it's no
longer kind of worth it this is pure
Nostalgia for me but the there's not
there's nothing better I I you know I
love packed sandwiches I think there's
something about it that is just so kind
of great it's like yeah I could just
[__] Japanese I no [__] no I can just
live off bread into some filling like I
feel like a there's something to bad it
just gets me happy M um and I love it I
think Greg does deserve it more though
I'll be real with you yeah that was my
biggest problem where I I saw this and I
was like this mother like if we're going
down this route this [__] really
thinks the me Tesco meal deal is better
than like Gregs if we're in like our
Matrix simulation you hand me both your
like meal deal or cheese and onion PTI
or sausage and bean melt I'm like all
right give me the give me the give me
the pasties um but I had to WP it I had
to WP it yeah all right and then bottom
middle Fried Chicken Fried just fried
chicken in general Fried Chicken listen
I you know we've gone on about this
boneless stuff I appreciate all fried
chicken bone in boneless it's all God TI
you um we're being that's what they want
us to distract ourselves with um I like
wings a lot but I think Fried Chicken
just takes it for me um right but even
fried chick kind of fried chicken just
just any Fried Chicken Korean Fried
Chicken's really good too I like
Nashville hot chicken too it's really
nice oh that is good yeah if you like
all kinds of fried chicken why did you
not order more types of fried chicken
when we were on tour uh it was always
boneless always always boneless because
it's the Comfort it's the the true the
true gigachad of realizing Fried Chicken
is not of the flavors of fried chicken
the bone and bone out it's the dips the
dips are what set the the flavors apart
and America does some amazing that's
where that's where you're just like see
cuz you're a fool cuz you don't like
drip you don't like dips drip you have
no drip you have no drip in America they
have figured out dips their dip game is
insane Ranch blue cheese but you'll go
to a place and they'll be like Chipotle
something you're like I don't even know
you can combine Chipotle Fila sauce
Chick-fil-A sauce or they'll be like uh
I think Chick-fil-A sauce is great but
Chick-fil-A chicken is even great like
without the sauce oh [__] off man you
talk the sauces [__] great I'm saying
it's great I'm saying like no it's great
but the sauces how many times do I hang
out with you guys and you just like
racing everything based on the source
and I'm just like it's not always about
the source no it is it it's not always
about the source it really it is not no
way eat some eat some plain ass [__]
chicken unseasoned chicken I'm taking
the dip any day honey mustard God Tia
like Smokey Smoky Chipotle God Tia
natural hot you're not real Chicken
Lovers I I refuse I love chicken but the
dip is what elevates it and in my mind
Fried Chicken inhibits that the best uh
and I I you know when we were on tour we
so many good places in every single
place with fried chicken is more it's
more than just the sauce it's about the
coating it's about the seasoning the
co how crispy it is there's so much to
Fried Chicken beyond the [__] you
have that perfect piece of chicken as
you describe and you put some [__]
dip into it yeah yeah it's like you know
when I have if I got if I got a KFC
right which I don't but if I do and have
I have like the leg I'll eat the leg raw
and then I'm like all right it's time to
mix it up now it's time for gravy to get
involved you know it's time to make this
better cuz I want I want to mix and
match flavors I want to have more than
one flavor he wants to do a combo
breaker dude let him
combo um um and uh Cesar salad salad
baby I love a Caesar salad I especially
you know in America it's such a Gamble
you either get like the most dog [__]
Caesar salad or you get such a good one
and I I admit sometimes they go too hard
with the SE the dressing and they add
too much stuff that makes it not healthy
when you get the perfect Caesar salad
it's like an Awakening you're like oh my
God it tastes good I feel great and it's
just such a good texture the croutons
are with the sauce and a little bit of
shaved Parmesan chees my one criticism
of Caesar salad that I've had in the
past is that sometimes the croutons just
out of nowhere when you take a big
mouthful of it and you just stab your
[__] mouth I prefer smaller in this
picture the croutons are those croutons
are huge I prefer little chunks of
croutons like just give meex Cub yeah I
love the cubes I know to me like Caesar
salads are like probably my least
favorite salads no the dressing's so
good I love the anchovy sauce it's so
good it just feels like too heavy you
know sometimes what's your favorite like
vinegarette yeah I love vinegarette
vinegarette all the way if I'm ordering
a salad I'm like making like commitment
to order like because I that means I'm
craving something light you know Caesar
salad is you can have a light Caesar
salad not in America you can't yeah but
that's why like I like it I like it in
the UK I like it in Japan it's you know
you can you can and that's why I like
when you get to make it yourself you can
apply the amount of dressing you want
I've recently come around to like cob
salads like I used to not really like
salads but like I think I've slowly kind
of started to appreciate C salad more I
love Caesar as well don't get me wrong
it's the best dressing it's the best
number one baby number one all the way I
just wish some places in America would
stop drowning that [__] in the sauce I
love the sauce but sometimes it's too
much but sometimes you go to a place
right and they homemade they make the
the sauce homemade and it's like so
anchovy and I love that I love it when
it's super fishy the anchovy is good and
with chicken chicken breast like
shredded so God TI what a what a what a
[__] chicken caesar salads yeah
they're pretty
good it's so good I love it all right
all right coffee unmatched and uh you
know I'm very surprised that you did not
put tiasu you know it was going to be on
there it was going to be on you know
when you said tiasu when I was talking
about my I should have replace it with
the shortcake I think tiasu might be
higher for me than short cake I you know
what I think it's cuz ultimately I'm a
Savory guy until I die and I think even
though I love tiramisu there's I I think
the Savory food still gaps it in my mind
yeah that's fair I just love I love salt
and I love Savory Foods all of these are
like very salty foods generally um and I
really like salt I'm I'm going to die of
stomach cancer probably but I love salt
sodium Overlord I love salt uh I I
there's never an occasion I won't go for
something Savory over something sweet oh
no 100% 100% um so yeah that's my food
3x3 and that is Al food 3x3 let us know
in the comments below whose opinions are
right whose opinions are wrong listen I
know I'm going to be clowned on but I
don't care I I have the I know my what I
love and hey we don't have to tell you
uh but there's probably going to be a
shitload of food 3x3 that uh unfolding
in the subred show us on the sub show us
like I'm just I think the most
disappointing pick out of everything so
far spag ball I just I thought you were
better Joey I thought you were better
you know that's my that's my precious
memory with my grandma that I won't let
anyone take away from me
okay Grandma said sorry for this
comments hey but look at all these
patrons though let's see what kind of
food Tes they have I wonder if they're
better or worse than what we have but
let us know down in the comments and uh
hey if you want to support the show then
head on over to our patreon ./ trast
also follow us on Twitter send us memes
on the subred and if you ha our face
listen to us on Spotify thanks so for
watching Gamers and we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
byebye